this is a dead lamprey gradually rotting  over 200 days in a box of seawater the  lamprey is a living relative of early  vertebrates it's part of an unglamorous  experiment by a team from the University  of Leicester in the UK they wanted to  find out how animals decay because  paleontologists rely on animal remains  to draw conclusions about evolution the  team found that the soft squidgy bits of  these eels perished before harder  cartilage like material in their gills  mouths and tail and as rotten luck would  have it the bits that go first are the  most informative for studying vertebrate  evolution this means that the remains  may not be representative of what the  creatures look like alive and that's a  problem for fitting species into  evolutionary trees the teams say that  this decay bias might mean we need to  reconsider many conclusions about the  early evolution of vertebrates  you